I used to work at the Chop Shop it was
chill decent hours good benefits you
could work while you were high which I
never did because that's it responsible
anyway we did a lot of work for the
stool who stole Pontiacs the Pontiac
bandit Hey I just picked him up on a
dozen counts of identity theft his
name's Doug Judy you ever seen him
before
Oh beautiful
I think he's into me he said he wants a
deal he has information about some dude
who steals Pontiacs Pontiacs
he knows about the Pontiac bandit listen
to me he specifically said he knows a
guy who steals Pontiacs I just said that
chill man okay okay sorry okay let's do
this super horny yeah come on Rosa
we can play act with his mom for two
minutes to get a lead fine
one false move and I tase you in front
of your mom should you be at work not
too busy to see my mama oh mama this is
my girlfriend Rosa and this is my
personal assistant mangy Carl ah that's
nice to meet you you could just call me
Carl mangy Carl used to be a homeless
gentleman I work with a charity that
finds jobs for down-on-their-luck white
people damn you a good assistant I could
get used to this how long till it
usually gets back to you mmm like 10
minutes chill mangy I can't chill never
been this close before
I got a mint you run through Yasim makes
me want you to catch him thank you are
these laser discs yeah I robbed a Tower
Records back in 92 kept my faves Doug
Judy who Blade Runner Tron Oh Fievel
goes west yes sir love that little mouse
his journey a story of America I could
not agree more Fievel Papa Fievel
hey cuz I'm not his mom put this stupid
braid in my hair
oh it's beautiful yeah it's cute please
have my children I gotta say the suit is
growing on me what's good is it triple
breasted somehow there's no such thing
what about the girl in Total Recall
triple bitties Judy you're under arrest
trans near hey Rosa mayor Christmas girl
shut up take a good look kids this is
what happens I present to you the
seventh wonder of the world Doug Judy
aka the Pontiac bandit foiled at last
thank you very much all right that's
enough Judy this is my moment you are
not to enjoy it I can't help it proud of
you like a son to me a white crispy son
how would that even work am i adopted no
your mother's just really pale almost
invisible look I say the only way we
make a deal with Doug Judy is if you can
give us the top guy Tito Ruiz I can give
you Tito Ruiz oh come on
Judy I mean how do we even know this is
real this guy's a huckster
he's a lie guy brought as a point you
have been a lie guy to us before thank
you give me some details reason I was
selling in Attica in the 90s he texted
me last week need some cars to deliver
his product I said no because drugs are
stupid
except for weed in sex pills man has
needs Rose aha
I can't think of your last name baby
says I'm going to jail I won't enjoy my
time left on the outside put me up in
5-star hotel like the Royce unlimited
room service and minibar privileges
three-star Hotel like the Brooklyn earth
$60 a day meal allowance no minibar
four-star hotel like the Oneida 204 no
minibar or alcohol but I get to go crazy
on candy and this agreed oh one last
thing
Diaz
has to be nice to me Omaha - call me big
sugar - huge mistake but she'll never
agree to that Norman let's do this big
sugar oh did you see the menu
Lobster Thermidor Baked Alaska it's so
fancy don't even sound like food yeah
come on or so or do it or no thanks
I'm on duty come on Peralta you gonna
let the criminal have all the fun all
right fine I'll have one
Lobster Thermidor extra Thermidor on the
side I have no idea what I'm ordering me
neither
we're like culinary Magellan's you know
how we take this to the next level
Rose robes
[Music]
teto do he spooks real easy so no
there's no way you're going in alone
we're coming with you
I've already got my cover story worked
out my name is Dante Thunderstone I
stole my first car at the tender age of
nine yet the fam for yourself since your
mother was struck by lightning while she
was pregnant with me she passed I lived
some say that makes Zeus my dad o mythic
hope and Rosa you could be my wife Rosa
why would you take your wife with you to
meet a drug dealer because we partners
in everything we do I know that voice
get ready it's time for some smoosh song
talk Judy the Pontiac bandit he's here
we got songs about smooshing songs for
smashing - someone's - the kids this is
the all-ages piano lounge I brought you
here because I'm in peril peril don't
this my peril somebody's trying to kill
me
and I need protection so I'll set for my
best friend I am NOT your best friend
I'm your worst enemy get that through
your head it's this kind of bickering it
makes us such an adorable couple
whatever Judy you're under arrest you
can't arrest me boo we're in
international waters which is also why I
can smoke as much weed as I want welcome
to the high seas no no way that that's
true Amy tell me I can arrest him right
now Judy's right we have no jurisdiction
technically this boat flies under the
flag of uzbek is done
oh girl knows about the whose bags oh I
got five down I figured out the theme
it's boats okay I get it she's smart and
lovable you're scrappy and lovable
together you just lovable lovable okay
so where's this hitman Judy look I don't
know who they sent but he's all about
of his manifest somebody bought in his
San Juan name Henry Cole's
Henry Street and Cole Street that's the
corner of your old chop shop in Brooklyn
this isn't alias I'm a porter but he
checked out Henry Cole's cabin he hasn't
been in a yet he's hiding somewhere on
his boat ready to jump out and kill me
at any moment
probably creeping around in my closet or
stowed away in a lifeboat so hide in a
wall holed up in the engine room
camouflaged in the shrubbery predators
down court
nope we are not having fun you will not
suck me in with your wily charms you
brought your own shuffleboard stick yeah
they're called tanks you should be glad
she has oh don't want to mess it with
another man's tang there's no way
they're called tangs it's true they are
and the disks are called biscuits tangs
and biscuits that is so dumb I
officially love shuffleboard clear a
path I'm about to quit my biscuit about
time you smile Jake you've been a real
Tang in the mud we're spending the rest
of this trip in your cabin Amy and I
will take sleep shifts to make sure
someone's always watching you thank you
that makes me feel super safe if you
want to smush I have a sleep mask and
noise cancelling headphones
ladies and gentlemen widows and widowers
welcome to the all-ages piano lounge
adults only show
I'm Horacio velvety dope name still song
I wrote myself called Rosa Rosa Rosa
goes like this Rosa Rosa Rosa Rosa
crowded in here girl and the lighting is
way too sexy to see anything right there
on the floor is the man you looking for
he's right in front of you a little bit
to the left my love my love my love my
left come on this way he's in a red
shirt no not the Asian dude I'm talking
about a bright red shirt that's the man
you're looking for that's the man you've
been looking for I gotta pee this is the
love song pretty huh well that ends my
show all of a sudden you've got a great
crowd thank you very much think of me
when you smush your real far away I'll
just assume you're finally admitting
with best friend no that is not what I'm
saying
thank you means a lot to me hey join us
see your crew just remember you got a
five lady don't be a Tang in the mud
check your pocket
boom boom boom better but this isn't
over
I will hunt you to the ends of the earth
I love you too
I'm so proud of us for being able to say
it what are you still standing there for
go son
you